Vietnam America's longest war its most
costly war its first military defeat and
his most nightmarish national trauma
people are still asking what went wrong
how and why did the u.s. get involved
was Vietnam a tragic mistake as liberals
claimed did the u.s. lose because of
self-imposed constraints as
conservatives claim could we have won
the war
we just unleashed the military machine
and bombed the North Vietnamese back to
the Stone Age what was the cost of
Vietnam the human cost the political
cost the economic cost to both the
United States and the Vietnamese one
person who has been researching these
questions for over 10 years
is William Gibson who has just published
a book the perfect war Technol war in
Vietnam with Atlantic Monthly press Bill
is a graduate of the University of Texas
where he did his undergraduate work and
he got his PhD at Yale University and is
now a professor of sociology at Southern
Methodist University in Dallas and we're
very pleased to have you with us today
on alternative views bill to discuss
your Vietnam but this is an incredible
book bill if you have read a lot about
Vietnam or if you have never read
anything about Vietnam this is the one
you should read because it shows the
picture from the top from the bottom and
it gives an explanation as to what
really happened there and why things
happen usually you come back with kind
of an empty feeling of wealth
frustration or not really knowing that
you after reading your book you
understand which is incredible thank you
and you get the emotional feeling the
impact as well as what was happening in
the mines and these incredible stories
like how the North Vietnamese were able
to bring down American jes just by lying
on their back and firing 45s and rifles
up into the sky but I'm getting ahead of
the story yes bill let's begin by
talking about what in your opinion is
distinctive about the Vietnam War what
about what brought about u.s.
involvement in this ill-fated adventure
the most distinctive feature of the
nah war that it was the first war in
modern times to be fought from a
managerial business perspective during
World War two
US industry made a massive contribution
to the war effort an American military
man and political leaders fully
appreciated that effort during world war
two the military partially adopted a
business model of organization for their
supply operation after World War two
they began to think of combat is also a
production process the officer corps
were seen not as gladiator heroes who
were leading men in combat but as war
managers in turn the enlisted men were
no longer the citizens of a nation but
they were workers managers and workers
worked on a production line to produce
death and the product then was enemy
body counts so just as American society
strength supposedly was high technology
capital intensive business so too would
we fight wars as high technology capital
intensive warfare we would literally dry
the other side bankrupt
so it's this production model of war or
what I call techno war that
distinguishes at a primary structural
level Vietnam from other warfare so then
in this way we couldn't lose because we
were fighting a small underdeveloped
untechnical third-world country with
peasants basically exactly from an
American perspective if the only thing
that counts in warfare is technology and
economics both in your economy and how
you translate your economy into your
military then week it was impossible for
us to lose it was theoretically
impossible for an underdeveloped peasant
economy to beat the United States it
just couldn't happen therefore whenever
we ran into a problem in 454 or 60 or 64
at every time the US was defeated we
always thought that if we escalated to
the next highest level we would win it's
a closed system and then why was Vietnam
chosen as the site
for the first techno war there's no
historical reason for Vietnam and was
really Vietnam is a country as a people
as a culture didn't really matter to the
Americans so there was nothing about
about the country per se to make us
fight there it was simply the time when
this whole apparatus of warfare was
developing these are the time when
situation in Vietnam was deteriorating
from an American perspective techno war
or this this production model of war got
its big push in the 50s because after
World War two when we had the hydrogen
bomb or the atomic bomb and then later
the hydrogen bomb and the Russians
didn't it seemed clear to us that our
mastery of the world was just
unsurpassed and we could not be
challenged but when the Russians had the
bomb we were in a situation of
potentially mutual destruction where
they could destroy our industrial
apparatus then this made the Americans
feel impotent and so the question came
is how can we develop a form of warfare
to any exercise our power in the world
without threatening nuclear war and the
idea developed by dr. Henry Kissinger
who at the time was a professor at
political science at Harvard was what's
called limited war and the idea was
because our economy was so big and
powerful
we could have guns and butter butter and
TVs and popcorn and drive-ins for
hula-hoops for the Americans at home and
limited war for an indefinite period of
time in the third world and because we
were so much richer we would just drive
the other side bankrupt and it was a
period where certain guerrilla movements
of national liberation rumors were
emerging we saw the Cuban Revolution in
1959 and there were third-world
revolutionary movements throughout the
western Africa the French and British
empires were deteriorating worldwide
certainly in Vietnam is a classification
that Vietnam had been a French colony
that went through a long process of a
goal so Vietnam was simply it was ready
we had our theory for a limited war we
had our apparatus in place at the time
Vietnam was a well by the time the
French had been thrown out can you give
us a brief history of Vietnam and their
struggle first against the Chinese and
the French etc leading up to American
intervention certainly the word Vietnam
originally in southern kingdom of Viet
and it was a part of China that well
didn't really break off it's like
Chinese immigrated there and they formed
in formed a racially distinct group and
tried to decline claim independence
Chinese emperors would invade Vietnam
hold the country for several hundred
years vietnamese Marella was a fighters
would throw the Chinese out the Chinese
would then invade and cold it for
another fifteen hundred years then the
Vietnamese would throw them out and hold
on for fifteen years this the struggle
between Vietnam and China for Vietnamese
independence went on for hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
years finally but time the Vietnamese
had finally defeated China they were in
Pride they were weak though and this is
the time when the West was expanding and
France was looking for a way to get to
China for the spice trade and they so on
and they ended up taking Vietnam so
France took Vietnam as a colony in the
1890s Vietnamese fought off and on
against the French from the 1890s on up
oh they just kept on fighting but then
in World War two the Communists
especially headed by Ho Chi Minh in Bo
Nugent Chapman they docto organized
better they fought against the Japanese
and then after declared their
independence in forty-five and
ironically American intelligence
operatives supported that effort
extensively and Ho Chi Minh as I
understand it looked at that time to the
United States as a model to develop his
country not to the Soviet here's his
position was that he had paid off
whatever he I felt he ideologically owed
to the Soviet Union and that he was a
free agent he was not getting any
assistance and at the America with the
declaration of independence and with its
stated anti imperialist policy was a far
better possible ally there's a model of
democracy
see for him to and at that time he was a
nationalist and a Democrat to some
extent certainly a nationalist how much
a Democrat I'm out I I wouldn't he was
prettiest pay lip service to the
synthetic values that's and the
anti-imperialist
but certainly Nationals well then the
Vietnamese defeated the French in 54
after eight years of extensive warfare
action it's a guerrilla warfare it's
important for us to understand the war
in Vietnam was one country it had been
tentatively divided into three
administrative zones by the fringe but
warfare was going on on all three when
the war ended in 54 the country looked
like a checkerboard some French in the
north some Vietnamese have yet men in
the north some french cities held in the
South other areas held by the by the
Vietnamese communists North and South
Vietnam didn't exist it was only a
checkerboard but then at the Geneva
peace talks in 1954 there was a land
swap Vietnamese forces moved north
French consolidated their forces in the
South a line was drawn a provisional
administrative boundary not a national
boundary not a political boundary and
administrative zone boundary the idea
was the country would be divided for two
years and there would be international
elections in 56 there were no such in
elections the United States moved in
well it's important to understand this
idea of North Vietnam is a separate
country that invaded South Vietnam is
wrong there was no North and South
Vietnam is two separate countries that
was a it was a checkerboard at the end
of 54 that got they got changed and what
happened in the south to begin the
resistance struggle when the grill went
in in 54 the Vietcong in the south were
told to put down their guns and that
they were going to engage in critical
struggle for two years in preparation
for the 56 elections that became
extremely dangerous dim the man the
Americans put in power immediately went
after and hunted down most of the
communists left this Democrats
nationalist noise
his family ruled Vietnam pretty much as
a dictatorship and finally by the late
50s the local Communists and guerrilla
and socialist and Democratic apparatus
was taking casualties so badly that they
had to renew the armed struggle to
survive and so simply then the southern
cadres put pressure on the north on the
Communist Party to like reopen the
military front and have a joint
political and military strategy as
opposed to simply trying to wait for
international intervention or by the
United Nations or something that that's
the origin of resistance and what was
the u.s. response to this then the oil
the response was quite simple this is uh
when the green berets who had originally
been formed to parachute into Eastern
Europe after to organize guerrilla
movements in Eastern Europe got
reformulated as counterinsurgency
experts and they were sent to Vietnam by
President Kennedy in 1960 it was also a
massive increase in CIA operations the
whole idea of covert warfare remembering
an encounter insurgency war if I
remember we had failed at the Bay of
Pigs in nineteen what 61 and so the idea
was that we must become experts at
fighting these wars of national
liberation that we must have new warrior
technicians who could intervene in
underdeveloped country countries and fix
things and the Green Berets were one
branch's fix-it men CIA operatives were
another various logistics people he
cannot economists were others we should
remember to understand the class
structure of Vietnam it's a poor rural
society most of the people are landless
peasants our own very small plots of
land there under subsistence agriculture
where a large part of their crop goes to
the landlord a small land owning clad
most PBS ins are Buddhists with
practiced elements of Confucianism as
well a small land owning class a lot
many of them at refugees from the north
many of them Catholic controls the
nation's wealth
so diem and the government diem uses in
the Army as a mechanism to collect rents
and during the first war against the
French the Vietcong had redistributed
the land to the peasantry
so when diem came to power and 54 with
the army and acted as agents of the
landlord to collect years of back rent
essentially the internal class
polarization increased one more time a
drove people the Vietcong into
revolutionary perspective exactly and
then GM had to use more and more
repression as a result of the
dissatisfaction of the and the
repression internment in essence that
the kind of that the Vietcong or
communist forces felt like they had to
resort to armed struggle again so this
is why you made your statement in your
book that ZM had an army but he didn't
have he was not a government that's
right no there was no effective
administration other than military
administration diem eventually replaced
all forms of village council all forms
of intermediary powers that that had any
linkage to to below were destroyed
instead our loyalty was from the top
down yet the American escalation didn't
really dramatically accelerate until
after dams assassination what brought
about this dramatic acceleration and
what you call techno war to Vietnam
where Dan was gone and all the other
Vietnamese generals began a power
struggle among themselves consequently
whatever government repressive apparatus
diem had collapsed desertions increased
radically defections to Vietcong units
became stronger and stronger by 64
American policymakers fear that there
would be a provisional Revolutionary
Government in my open provisional
Revolutionary Government in much of the
countryside once we had lost the minutes
goes to state US forces lost our the
French lost in 45 we lost again in 54 we
lost again in 63 64 we escalate P
American Nazis escalates in the face of
defeat not in the face of victory right
so massive defeat in 63 and 64 brought
of an the
the need for us ground troops and
sustained bombing of the north in order
to try to salvage the situation why
couldn't the US accept a defeat in this
small corner of the world the United
States has been unwilling to deal with
communism is a political social and
economic movement instead it gets seen
that we as Americans are the natural
beings of the world and the capitalism
is the natural economic order and that
our system is simply the essence of
human goodness in the essence of nature
therefore something very very different
from us is not another society with whom
one compares differences and makes
treaties with and so on and so forth but
instead is an alien presence if we're
nature they're anti nature or what I
call the for another during World War
two the Soviet Union did take over right
after World War two did invade and take
over Eastern Europe the Red Army did you
hold it as a buffer zone and they did
install puppet dictatorships there this
became the model for all American views
of communists and socialists of any kind
Americans did not understand internal
revolution they did not understand the
Chinese Revolution in the 40s that there
were like millions upon millions of poor
peasants who wanted land and survived
and that Mao Sato him in the Communist
Party offered them land and survival
whereas Chiang kai-shek was a World Lord
who offered them nothing so are they
able to see internal struggles for
socialism or communism or are unable to
see even internal struggles for national
independence against colonialism the war
gets divided into them in US and we are
the good guys and they're the bad guys
they are the foreign other they're
trying to move in so all forms of
communism get movements get seen in that
light so in this sense then any
particular movement in the world is not
just a particular movement in a
dirt-poor country let's remember how
dirt-poor Vietnam is then and we had
very little investment there instead any
movement is a sign of the global
movement against a few poor peasants win
in Vietnam that doesn't mean just that
they have that
few more people have a few more rice
instead that means that the for another
the monolithic machine has encroached
one more step and that with each other
step the rest of the world becomes in
peril this of course the domino theory
so like a contagious disease sort of
instead of like each country having its
own history and its own culture and its
own people it's as if the world is an
empty shell like a chessboard and see
the are side are their side and once
they get going just somehow a
mechanistic momentum will prepare all
communism to victory it's very and I'll
call it mechanistic anti-communism
because it's a mechanistic framework of
the world and the enemy is is for and
others they aren't really real enemy at
all it's an abstraction isn't that also
after two sides of this the other side
is the people the big decision makers
the foreign policy establishment as you
term it looking at the world on a more
realistic basis as general Maxwell
Taylor said in his book we have to keep
an iron grip on the third world country
because they're poor and they want
riches and the riches would have to come
from us so they look at any type of
victory such unique as an econ such as
in Vietnam as providing an example to
other third-world countries that if they
can do it and get away with it in
Vietnam they can get away with it you
know there's a universal side victory in
Vietnam was a universal sign of national
liberation victory everywhere defeat in
Vietnam means that all liberation
movements will give up their struggles
so bill given the fact of this
military-industrial complex in the
United States that had built up a new
military machine and model of warfare
given the mechanistic anti-communism
that was motivating the foreign policy
decisions of the u.s. foreign policy
establishment and given the collapse of
the diem South Vietnamese government in
Vietnam it was almost inevitable that
u.s. involvement would intensify that
this war was not an accident that this
war was not just a policy mistake but it
was a consequence basically of u.s.
foreign policy and US industrial and
military
development since World War two that
this was the test case this is where
they had the test a war machine and
start communism I really want to stress
together that I am one of the principal
arguments I'm trying to like critique in
my book is this notion that we just made
one mistake after another that nobody
was really responsible for anything the
things just sort of slipped up you don't
go to war that way you go to war far far
in advance in 64 when Johnson was making
announcements about the Gulf of Tonkin
and just sort of like how was the
surprise attack which it wasn't
in early 65 when they were making his
announcement in American public that
maybe we'd send a few thousand more
troops to Vietnam they fully expected to
send two hundred thousand people by the
end of 65 they another 160 100,000 by 66
and another hundred thousand by 67 with
the estimates were already there that it
be a take a half million men right is a
planned out war it was a plan warfare a
plan
escalation well let's talk about the war
itself and see how this techno lore
actually worked out itself in the ground
and in the air the use of helicopters
the helicopter war and the Search and
Destroy
can you describe these and how they
worked in that well let me quote a very
famous general Julian Ural generals
write books they're kind of like a
conditions they need to like write to
publish in order to get further promoted
at the hierarchy we normally don't
believe that but I think that way but
it's it's true and to justify their
actions and judge to justify their
actions alright us book is called
sharpening the combat edge the use of
analysis to reinforce military just a
military judgment it's published by a
department in the army and in the first
chapter you'll says that we could
compare Search and Destroy operations in
Vietnam to an assembly line that it was
a you know a literally a war factory
that the object it was like unlike a
world war to a world war one would you
have a continuous front going on
thousands of miles and you have major
offensives and then a counter-offensive
and then the law in Vietnam it's a
factory you turn the factory on you let
it run full blast all the
time and that's the managerial problem
how do you just allocate your resources
given the fact that you've already
decided to run at maximum capability to
put his body who this body counts
search-and-destroy means that somewhere
between several hundred and several
thousand American soldiers are going to
search a block of countryside for Viet
Cong or North Vietnamese troops and
they're going to try to engage them in
combat and course and destroy whatever
troops or whatever supplies they capture
in theory its strategic offensive
meaning it's a way to put the Vietcong
make them weaker but the moment to hunt
them down it's as if one hunters and
they're the prey the objective is to
kill the enemy so fast that we reach
what's called we called the crossover
point this is general william
Westmoreland term the crossover point
means you're killing the enemy faster
then they can replace their casualties
it's like you're going to drive the
other side bankrupt and so with all of
our high technology with our helicopters
our jet fighter bombers our tanks will
just grind them up now that's the theory
the practice of Search and Destroy often
turned out very differently in that part
of simply of a factory means a set of
routine operations and this routines
were quite visible to the Vietnamese for
example we just didn't all of a sudden
show up unannounced into an area and
begin the search instead you had to like
reconnaissance planes had to go over it
our Tillery guns had to shoot smoke
rounds into the jungle into the landing
zone so that all the other artillery
guns could sight in so they could like
fire protective artillery strikes around
the landing zone if you're any kind of
yet kong commander if you see a smoke
round coming up in the jungle while you
know that the americans are getting
ready to launch a
helicopter assault the aren't that many
clear zone that clear areas in in
mountainous territory are in swamps or
in in jungle you can tell where the
landing zone those are so many times the
Vietcong commanders had a very
substantial advance notice upon when the
Americans were going to begin an
operation consequently they had the
choice do we run and hide or do we
ambush the Americans then land the
second were first wave takes the landing
zone the second and third ways bring in
more artillery if your viet cong
commander you get out your compass and
your map you draw a circle a radius or
on their map and that will tell you
because you know that american artillery
a 105 millimeter howitzer has a 10,000
meter radius so you know that the
Americans will not march further outside
the range of their howitzers so you can
tell where the Americans are going to
march do you run and hide or do you
fight so this so the same kind of
principle goes on it's in essence they
knew where we were but we did not know
where they were and they had the they
had the initiative they then had the
initiative is their terrain it's their
terrain so it has even by the military's
own statistics roughly three-quarters of
the battles in Vietnam were initiated by
the Viet Cong and NVA meaning they
ambushed us forces and could make a
decision also most battles ended when
the Viet Cong and NVA wanted them ended
they could reich initiate conduct and
break contact and that's those are two
crucial definitions of combat initiative
and your other statistic that only in
two percent of the Search and Destroy
missions did we actually make contact
original contact with the Vietnamese so
it was their choice the whole time and
as I understand the soldiers themselves
on the ground they didn't like this
because they were the ones who would
have to take the casualties first to
lure the Vietnamese into battle
so that then the Americans would know
where to send the planes and where to
send the artillery you send out a patrol
in order to get it ambushed in order to
mark a target with a smoke
Crockett from a helicopter or so so that
then the Jets can come in and they pom
the area in other words you have to get
ambushed before you can find the enemy
you know when I began my Vietnam
research I had a hint that I was going
to find a very cavalier attitude towards
whether or not the Vietnamese lived or
died I was surprised to understand the
commands attitude towards their own
soldiers but this think about it we're
talking at a production model of war
again or techno war this is a u.s. one
minute these are the US war managers we
have a draft we can replace all the cat
all the labor that we lose can be
replaced and indeed it's like migrant
labor force we're almost sort of like
say we had a farm when you bring them in
for a year oxen Chicanos anyway quite on
well not most but a whole lot of them
are there are there poor working-class
whites the idea was so what if they walk
into an ambush we take some casualties
that way but then we'll call in our
airstrikes and call in artillery fire
and we'll use our technology then to get
the body count so in essence the ground
troops were bait they were being sent
out on operations to be ambushed and
that's not a good way to survive in
warfare night movement that was suicide
I was one of the worst patrols you could
ever go out on the purpose of it was for
you to walk up on Charlie and for him to
hit you and then for our hardware to
wiped him out
we were used as scapegoats to find out
where they were that was all we were
bait Hale they couldn't find Charlie any
other way so they loved to us to run
into a whole bunch of them that way they
could plaster him and they'd have a big
body count then the general gets another
goddamn
and a big promotion let's also note
again the highest officer routinely on
the ground during Vietnam was a captain
a captain's company commander
a company had at most about a hundred
and forty people in it that would be at
full strength most combat units never
operated full strength everyone above
captain's level battalion commanders the
man who commands for companies all
battalion level officers brigades
brigades Khmer several battalions
divisions has several regiments or
brigades all the rest of those choppers
all the rest of those commanders are in
helicopters flying at minimum at 1500
feet because 1500 feet is the maximum
range of a 50 caliber machine gun when
used as an anti-aircraft weapon which
until the latter part of the war was the
largest anti-aircraft weapon the
Vietcong had so the managers were
relatively safe in this process whereas
the workers who are suffering the
occupational safety hazard hazards on on
the ground was it a success in terms of
the numbers and the body counts did they
actually in their own in human logic
succeed or were the costs greater than
the benefits and even in terms of their
own logic several things happened for
one all the American commanders and
helicopters communicated in uncoded
English to their subordinate officers
and ground troops
the Vietcong in NVA were able to buy
American radios on the black market and
capture others they routinely listened
in in to all the orders there are many
stories of people of Vietcong hearing
American orders and then taking actions
to circumvent them so the sheer
arrogance of we know we're in our
helicopters we have all this stuff we
don't have to care we don't have to pay
attention to our enemy and end up
costing American lives so that part
didn't work
it took within a year or so
by late 66 or so via cognate NVA knew
how long it was going to take an
American airstrike to get there
sometimes they can make a terrible
miscalculation and get caught out in the
open but an astute enemy commander it
could make a reasonable judgment on how
long he could stay in combat before he
had to run like hell because the f-4s I
thinking look at other Huey's or the
gunships were coming too after him so a
lot of times ambushes would be quite
brief in the enemy would break off
contact
well we've mentioned body count a couple
of times let's get into that and the
whole framework of corruption and lies
and cover-ups it ik it's very it's
simple proof we found it so far if the
success in war is purely an enemy body
count yes because we're trying to drive
the other side bankrupt and let's
presume that oh you and Doug are which
I'm a general and that like your
lieutenants are captains right maybe
your captain come in a company commander
somewhere you know under pressure I'm
under pressure to produce a body count
and it's a colonel same acronym
battalion commander if I don't meet my
quota my career is over with I'll be
relieved of command and if you're
relieved of combat command then your
your ticket up the hierarchy is gone so
I'm going to squeeze you and back in
some units it kind of where the informal
rule was if you don't meet your body
count quota then we're going to like
you're not coming men off the field well
just leave you I will bring you some
more ammo some more food some more water
but don't expect you know you've got to
like produce the goods I knew if I came
back without a body count or at least
prisoner and get my ass chewed so I kept
the patrol out well I talked to too many
soldiers who were wounded no the ones I
saw in Japan and they told me that some
units were given a quarter for the week
and if they didn't get it they were just
sent right back out again
are you under pressure remember severe
severe pressure what do you do well you
can do several things one you can just
invent a body you can just out of the
thin air and just like say call up and
have it like tell everyone in your unit
tell them tell your entire class their
UT the fire off their m16 for about for
a minute called a mad minute and call up
on the radio and report that I have a
you have a body count of 30 our body
count of 5 or something like that or say
you get ambushed Frank and your whole
company gets ambushed you call it an
airstrike and you're calling an
artillery strike and there's an armored
unit nearby and you actually have an
engagement and you find some enemy
bodies well how do you then even to do
well if you found 10 bodies and you've
got three different units artillery air
and infantry involved who's going to get
the credit what if you don't give credit
to the artillery what do you think might
happen then what if you say you've fired
but you missed is that sound like a wise
policy to you their artillery commander
isn't going to give you any support that
he might be kind of slow next time
around
are those f4 pilots might have to have
they might get a little slow too it's in
your interest to reward everyone and
since everyone is under the same system
everyone needs body counts why sure we
give you 50 Air Force we give you 50
gunships we give you 50 artillery and we
on the ground well I've got five bodies
and I've got five rifles we're count
each rifle is a five persons killed so
that gives us 25 and while we were out
stumbling around we found 10 enemy
grenades Tom beg your pardon 10 graves
will count them too and body part in
body parts say we find an arm or a leg
and say because sometimes really when
the air strikes did hit you can't blow
people to smithereens unlike the war
movie where everyone has nice discreet
death yeah
in a real war it's quite gruesome there
are stories for people from different
units had to fight over arms and legs to
determine who was going to get the kill
count for their unit and of course they
got the got even more pernicious because
they would slaughter Vietnamese
civilians and include them I mean
children women old people include them
as part of the body count as well well
we should get clear on that about in
some areas of the war where US forces
were fighting uniformed North Vietnamese
troops there weren't too many civilian
casualties but a whole whole lot of
Vietnam battles occurred way inside the
country where there were Viet Cong and
Viet Cong and the villagers were were
very much the same people well now on
Search and Destroy missions they told us
to kill everything that moves
so we killed everybody
I just happened to be standing alongside
the officer when the radio man said look
sir we got some children rounded up what
do you want us to do with him and the
officer says god damn it marine you know
what to do with him kill the bastards
you ain't got the goddamn balls to kill
a marine I'll come down and kill the
bastards myself the Marine said yes sir
and hung up the phone and about two or
three minutes later I heard a lot of
automatic fire and a lot of children
screaming I heard babies crying I heard
children screaming their lungs out
Search and Destroy reached the point
where if any say you many units burn
down villages routinely and then you go
into village and you burn it and and you
see their bunkers there because all
everyone in Vietnam had a bunker to hide
in and you hear a noise and maybe you
maybe you scream and try to get somebody
out that maybe you just throw the
grenade in or people start to run away
from you and well if they run from you
they must be your enemy and so you shoot
them and say well running becomes a sign
of an enemy well we'd been out for about
three hours and I really haven't seen
anything was too hot but then I saw this
figure in black pajamas running along a
paddy dike about 300 meters ahead and to
the left oh hey I got one I hollered ten
o'clock he's mine then I muttered the
warning to halt
you know regulations don't lie down lie
so I dropped to one knee squeeze the
trigger crack figuring black went flying
like a piece of paper and Augusta win
holy got some Morgan shouted not shot
baby not shot said Newcombe when we
reached the body I nudged the corpse
face up with my boot there's a woman
about 55 60 Wally says stupid [ __ ] what
she run for
we were in a free-fire zone and we saw
women and a woman a child running across
and the captain says well they're there
they're running well in a free-fire zone
if they're running they're wrong they're
the enemy so we shot him whole squad
opened up on her the next morning we
went out and we could see the cap of a
child it was bloodied and you could see
where the mother had dragged the child
away troops are under there afraid
they're trying to survive they're in a
desperate situation they're under a high
pressure to produce a body count there
so yes we got into sustained slaughter
of that means villagers you go through
and you look at a man's hands and if
he's a true farmer he has calluses and
if he's a gorilla who's only a fake
farmer he doesn't so you go and you look
at the hands and those that he doesn't
have enough calluses and you haul him
away you send him to an interrogation
center or you look at the ankles if a
man has a gorilla he must be running out
there in the jungle getting his ankles
all scratched up where if he's a farmer
he wouldn't have so many scratches so
people would go American soldiers would
go around and look at the ankles or if
he's a gorilla if you actually meet a
farmer by day and a fighter by night you
must not be getting much sleep so you
can't have circles under your eyes so US
soldiers will go in and look into the
eyes of the Vietnamese and try to decide
how many how many bags they had and then
you have too many bags you get you get
hauled off we it was not our country it
was not our culture we did not speak the
language and by the American way of
looking at war language culture history
class structure these matters didn't
didn't matter what matters we had the
hardware and they did well as the pilot
of a helicopter gunship we had a rule
about the use of evasive action anyone
taking evasive action could be fired
upon they never explained
why or even what it was but anyway there
was one incident I recall where we flew
over a large rice paddy and there were
some people down there working in the
rice paddy maybe dozen or 15 individuals
and we passed over their heads well they
didn't take any action but we could tell
there was nervous but they didn't try to
hide or anything so we hovered just a
few feet off the ground among them with
our two helicopters we turned on our
police sirens and boy when they heard
the police sirens they started to
disperse and so we opened up on them
just shot them all down
well 6:30 in the evening and still
daylight
and they said there was some VC out
there and they called on us so we fired
out there and killed off seven of them
well word comes back to us we killed
seven rice farmers carrying their hose
they're trying to make it back to the
village you see we'd set up this curfew
6:00 p.m. to 6:00 a.m. and so it was up
to them to be out of there by that time
but hell they didn't carry any
wristwatches they didn't have any idea
what time it was so yes people got
hauled away for interrogation and never
came back
yes many many villages were burned to
the ground and blown up and yes many
many many many of the enemies men women
children
chickens water buffalo pigs piglets
often were killed all from how he went
into a village the stories are you shot
everything and burned the crops and
putting the crops and that was hmm and
their houses boy you know if the people
don't treat you right when you walk
through that village you can give them a
hail yeah they give you that snotty look
they can do you they won't say nothing
to you and we expected them to run out
and welcomed us like at World War two
type of stuff you know hey GI Hey well
as soon as we step outside the village
the captain radios in we're under heavy
contact and
right away oh those phantom jets start
coming in and dropping them 500-pound
bombs the whole village is leveled and
we go on to the next village and that is
Search and Destroy
all this was I guess part of what you
call the mayor Guk rule yes essentially
if it's deadness Vietnamese as VC you
know what it is armies have documents
called rules of engagements that are
supposed to specify when you can open up
fire and when you can't
I'm civilians anyone but they weren't
used much at all
instead other kind of rules happened
like I said if they run they're an enemy
or if they have black pajamas that was
one rule so I mean it's not that any
debt and he's wearing black garb was the
enemy of course all peasants that wore
that is the national dress so there are
all kinds of these fake rules that
supposedly distinguish being friend from
foe but all these rules were wrong in
that we just didn't know the culture
they were kind of like fabrications that
Americans invented to try to make
themselves feel legitimate about who got
shot you know but ultimately people saw
through this and said look we wanna see
what's in practices this is the mirror
grue grue grue if it's dead it's
Vietnamese SPC any Vietnamese we shoot
we're going to count it something
there's also the factor of racism too
like sure wonder how much they would
have done this if they'd been fighting
German is probably much less of course
this [ __ ] slope slant dink one
definition of a dead Vietnamese was
believers if they've been napalm they
were called crispy critters and a
one-liner went when we killed a pregnant
woman we counted as two VC one soldier
and one cadet now what you do is you
load all the friendlies the friendly
Vietnamese on two ships and take them
out to the South China Sea and then you
bomb the country flat
then you sink the ships I'd like to burn
the whole country down and then start
again with Americans bomb the schools
and church is bombed the rice fields to
show the children in the courtyard just
what napalm can do strafe the town and
kill the people drop napalm in the
square get out early every Sunday and
catch them at the morning prayer throw
candy to the our van and gather them all
around take your 20 millimeter cannon
and mow the bastards down this also
tapped a certain sadism not only in
soldiers in the field but also
intelligence people there were people
who would collect ears and fingers and
even heads and even intelligence people
would admit that they really got off to
beating up the people they were
interrogating you know and gave him a
nice buzz a thrill to do it when you go
through soldiers novels and memoirs many
have made valiant efforts to try to talk
about the perverse eroticism of warfare
a word that you say it isn't clearly a
very strong statist dimensions a lot of
rape in the field as well as killing or
a lot of rapes followed by killings and
mutilations well weed we know me before
five of us we go into the village and
take a girl and bring her out into the
jungle we tell her to lie on the ground
and don't scream otherwise we'd kill her
immediately and then well how many of
our guys there were well they did what
they want to with her his guys were in a
good mood they let her go they weren't
they kill her
well the girls were unconscious after
they'd been repeatedly raped and then
after they got through raping him three
of the gi's took hand flares and they
shoved him in the girls vaginas
the girls were bleeding from their
mouths noses and faces and a páginas
then the gis lighted the exterior
portion of the flares and they exploded
inside the girls they their stomachs
just exploded well one day I was driving
back while driving on a back road and a
guy comes over to me and he says he
needs some gasoline didn't say why well
I look over and I see this girl and
she's stripped and she's tied to two
wooden stakes I don't know what they've
done to her before I got there well they
poured gasoline all over the girl and
they lighted it they lit it and then
they just stood there and watched her
burn up its it if you look at a body
count system and you see if that's the
only thing that counts right
the body count if that's that that's
what rewards and punishments are
distributed by if that's your ethic and
if your own command doesn't really care
whether you survive then clearly you're
in a world where anything goes it
becomes a boy at the times we are apart
although it becomes a war for survival
or a war to hold on to your ethics I
think a good example of this Oliver
Stone's movie platoon which is currently
in release MCOs a US military unit that
severely defy it divided between one
group who convinced atrocities and
others who thinks it's a horrible
horrible situation and I think that's a
good a good illustration of probably the
kind of dynamics that occurred in many
many units it isn't is that everyone is
a killer or a sadist it's as if you're
in a structure where
a significant component of your troops
engaged in such behavior but not
everyone so it seems that then you know
we talked about atrocities and we talked
about meal I when you use that term
atrocity it applies your exception to
that's not a good way to look at it here
let me lie and atrocities were just
business as usual yes in a lie seems a
little well organized in particular well
organized but certainly certainly may
lie wasn't the only village in Vietnam
it was burned down and where everybody
inside it was shot that is that is that
is not true at all in fact though is
precisely this inability on the ground
war to distinguish between friend and
foe VC and peasant farmer that led to
the next dimension of Technol war the
pacification programs the fact that they
weren't able to tell who the enemy was
meant that they had to clear out the
whole country simply if you can't tell
friend from foe
then you depopulate the countryside and
move them into rescue into concentration
camps and move them into urban slums
it's not easy to depopulate a
countryside there are several major
techniques ones DeFilippo d--ation you
simply destroy the food base of the
country this is where Agent Orange comes
in Agent Orange and agent blue and agent
white were sprayed on millions of acres
of cropland other millions of acres of
forest would affiliate it so with the
food based on people have to move
secondly certainly bombing attacks on
villages which were quite quite
extensive discourage encourage people to
move and then third actual Search and
Destroy operations where villages some
of which everyone has killed others in
which you simply surround the village
move everyone out then burn up the
village and move them remove them these
three modes millions and millions of yet
nummies lost their homes and were sent
to concentration camps into urban slums
and what's so interesting is the
Americans saw this is progress
this was urbanization rural is bad urban
is good so even though they have nothing
it was brought as a seen as a sign of
progress to bring Vietnamese in
where you could show them TV and make
them work in American bases and so on
and so forth we've seen this I think a
more sophisticated job than being a
peasant farmer this is also part of that
same syndrome of not seeing the enemy in
the as a culture or as individuals or
people but seeing them just as mirror
images of ourselves like the bombing of
North Vietnam was supposed to hurt them
if they destroyed their capacity to have
consumer goods certainly and so the ayah
same idea it you would think from the
American perspective that no Vietnamese
cared about their home that they didn't
care about their land and their dog in
their ancestors gray than their rice
fields and their trees that instead
simply just to have this new good have
this consumer go to live in the urban
area but that in itself was just an
unmitigated good the right people's
lives were not importantly the human
dimension was completely lost and
instead of Americans then we can count
how many TVs were imported this month
how many Honda's yeah logic effective
war was inapplicable to Vietnam in a way
certainly that's exactly it could in
many ways a tremendous destruction but
it could not stop a very powerful United
people who were trying to change their
lives and this will be our topic for our
next program we're running out of time
for today and next week we'll see the
limitations of tech-noir of why it
failed in Vietnam we'll also discuss
what's wrong with the liberal and
conservative interpretations of Vietnam
we'll see what lessons we can draw from
the Vietnam experience we also will talk
about some other aspects of the Vietnam
War the Tet Offensive for instance that
was a big turning point in the war a lot
of revisionist historians particularly
conservative said that it was an
American victory was it it wasn't not
we'll also talk about this fascinating
phenomenon in which the American army
pretty much refused to fight or many
elements than it did as a matter of fact
it started attacking their own officers
and senior enlisted people in this
phenomenon known as fragging
and we'll conclude with a discussion of
some of the parallels to Central America
of some of the failures of US policy in
Central America and how they can be
illuminated by the failures of the
policy in Vietnam so bill thanks for
coming tonight interesting informative
discussion and we'll look forward to
next week
welcome to alternative views this is the
second on her two-part series about the
Vietnam War with Bill Gibson who wrote
an incredible book about the Vietnam War
called the perfect war Technol war in
his book the perfect war Technol war in
vietnam was recently published by
Atlantic Monthly press and his so far
received some extremely good reviews it
was favorably reviewed in The Wall
Street Journal Kirkus reviewed ascribed
it as a perceptive cogent significant
and so far the best analysis of the
meaning of America's only military
defeat highly recommended Gloria Emerson
in a review described the book as
although many valuable books on the war
exist as records of pain and endurance
there is no work that achieves what this
does because he might just say this from
our most comfortable lies and sad
delusions William Gibson should be
honored and john stockwell describes
this book has an all of my research on
the subject I found nothing to compare
with dr. Gibson's perfect war for
invaluable insights into u.s.
methodology and it's hideously results
in the war tonight we're going to talk
about the things we didn't cover we're
going to talk about Tet the importance
of that the Tet Offensive we're going to
talk about how the United States Army a
lot of them didn't they decided they
weren't going to fight that war anymore
we're going to have an evaluation of the
Vietnam War how many how did it people
look at it from various aspects and
we'll also take a final look at have we
learned our lessons or are we still
fighting fighting Technol war in Central
America or at least planning to what is
your interpretation of tech-noir how do
we get involved in
techno war means you fight war is a
production process the military became
deeply impressed with big businesses
contributions of world war ii after
world war ii the military then decided
that not only would our the supply
operations be organized along corporate
lines but the actual conduct of warfare
would be organized along corporate lines
the officer corps were the managers the
enlisted men were the workers the
product was enemy body counts just as
American business prided itself on high
technology capital intensive production
systems so to where our military has
high technology capital intensive
warfare to out produce we would kill
more of them than they would of us
that's techno war why was it applied in
Vietnam because after world war in the
50s the Soviets had the atomic bomb they
could then destroy our economy our the
base of our power if we intervene
militarily in the war in the world with
too much force the object wind was to
fight limited war for indefinitely in
the third world we would use our we
would just send our production system
over there and drive the other side
bankrupt why Vietnam Americans saw
communism not as another type of social
organization as another culture as
another political system but instead
they saw Americans as the good the
natural the godlike and the communism
was a foreign and other an alien kind of
being the world was divided into simply
two types of people communist and
non-communist and therefore it was like
debit or credit their side or our side
at the time the Fiat nummies overthrew
the French in the late 50s we had our
theory of limited war in tact we had our
conventional forces ready to go by the
late 50s Vietnam was simply a convenient
mode place to test out this new theory
of warfare techno war and a place to
drive the for another back as you
pointed out something fascinating in
your book about how a major part of us
supported a certain part of the war was
to win the hearts and the minds of the
Vietnamese through importing us
commodities to them yes US government
put up the money to import these
commodities and created the whole
infrastructure for it and rather than
win in the hearts and minds of the
overwhelming majority of the Vietnamese
people it just created more corruption
and inequality do you want to talk about
that aspect of you it's just hard for us
to realize how much money was poured
into that country in so many ways if you
were a high Vietnamese General or
Colonel in the South Vietnamese
government Army positions were like
business positions and it was most
American aid was on me it was for sale
on the international market by the time
and arrived the level of theft is
unbelievably high and the only reason
it's like rather than try to control the
theft the American government
essentially made the decision look theft
by the officer court is the price we
have to pay for continuing the war so
therefore in order that something
reaches the Vietnamese people will just
send more and more and more and there
was an element of truth in that but also
the greater truth was that simply
corruption became compounded and the
riches became became greater we're
talking about millions and millions upon
hundreds of millions of dollars made or
even the currency manipulation currency
fraud was endemic if you knew how to
play the game you could get rich simply
by exchanging your money from from
dollars to piasters to military script
and back again
you know just nothing just by playing
playing with the rules a little bit so
but it didn't it created massive
inflation it meant that life for most
people got worse and it's what were your
jobs available run a few people on top
were able to make money off this this
stealing the American aid on the bottom
what were your jobs open for you well
you could work for the Americans you
could work on their base you could be an
interpreter maybe if you had minimal
language skills these are all if you're
a man if you're a woman the estimates
are they throwing like 1/2 million
Vietnamese women engaged in some kind of
commercial sex prostitution massage
parlors
you want to call it which girls there's
a whole multi-level sexual marketplace
um drugs and other drugs the drug huge
huge heroin importation coming from all
places coming from Laos and the CIA was
running a war in Laos with the hills
people and with the Laotian government
in order to buy the leaders of the hills
people by the Laotian government they
had to acquiesce to the heroin trade
tons of heroin were brought in on Air
America planes and Vietnamese Air Force
planes when we find in Bangkok and other
places and sold on in in to US soldiers
in Vietnam South Vietnamese civil and
military leadership was also heavily
involved in the narcotics business
general and subsequent President of the
Republic of Vietnam when Bantu ran one
major operation while when Kalki at
times there marshal premier and
vice-president ran another for orphans
what could you do
shoeshine business wasn't something kids
had to make money on the side shining
shoes was life or death issue going
through garbage dumps you know a very
dismal life in this new urban Vietnam
not a consumer paradise and then the
other hand you had the black market
where as you say in your book you could
buy in it you even buy tank armored
personnel carriers and of course the
Vietcong were tents with themselves
whenever they needed American goods they
could equip themselves without any
problem yet the other aspect of US
policy was air war part of it your most
brilliant chapters and descriptions in
your book are the magnitude and nature
of the air war in Vietnam that was
mainly I guess directed against North
Vietnam you want to discuss some
elements of air war if war is a factory
then clearly when you look at air war
we've got the biggest factory and they
have nothing by American reasoning the
North Vietnamese should have given up
the day the first bombs dropped on North
Vietnam because they had such a small
small industrial apparatus such a small
number of bridges and things that you
would think they would have just given
up but they didn't they were willing to
sacrifice their industrial apparatus
they were willing to absorb a massive
massive casualties and indeed contrary
to American mythology where the Vietcong
were simply to being totally supported
from the north roughly 80% of the
supplies the Vietcong used and even in
the 80% supplies the NVA used were
raised in the south a small number of
supplies were sent south it couldn't be
stopped no matter how hard the u.s.
bombed no matter how harsh it escalated
his campaigns no matter even after they
closed the ports at Haiphong and we
started systematically bombing the
railroad lines between China and Vietnam
it couldn't stop it the number of
supplies wasn't that great
on the other hand the area war did
mobilize the North Vietnamese people to
exert considerable degree everyone had a
job of one kind or another either
repairing the railroads repairing the
roads or taking over industry or working
in agriculture so it mobilized in
Consolidated that society to carry on
much like the Nazi attack on Great
Britain consolidated British morale in
World War two but on the other hand
people used to say well we ought Obama
back to the Stone Age and we just
practically did didn't we most people
don't recognize that the United States
Air Force and Navy dropped between 8
million and 15 million tons of bombs and
rockets on Southeast Asia in all of
World War 2 the United States dropped
2.1 million tons
so the minimum estimate then is about
four times greater than World War two
and it goes up to almost eight times
greater than world war ii and in
Westmoreland's 1967 report he has a
target category summary in the largest
category in there after vehicles is
buildings when you listen to the reports
of foreign observers on the ground what
the report is just about any modern
stone or brick structure over to
two-story over ones
dori was hit because those are the only
things that look like targets in essence
a lot of those were churches lot of more
hospitals a lot of them were schools
yes North Vietnam was bombed back to the
Stone Age there's no doubt about that
because they were not fighting a techno
or that type of them now we saw in the
previous program where this production
assembly line type of attitude resulted
in the demand for body count for the
land troops in the air war they also
have production quotas did they not and
the organization of this was alright the
unit of measurement is called a sortie
that's one fight by one airplane and Air
Force squadrons wings air for hope large
units have rates of production that they
are supposed to meet the Navy of the Air
Force and indeed we're in common in
competition with each other to see you
could quote be the most productive
therefore the object was to fly as many
missions as possible within a finite
period of time like a week or a month or
whatever
so rather than then pay attention to
really what you were bombing or to pay
attention to the safest way to protect
your pilots and the way to minimize
civilian casualties instead
military war managers devised ways to
maximize sortie rates and consequently
entered into serious irrational behavior
they like in ground war where US
commander treated their own ground
troops is expendable higher command
treated pilots is expendable they would
often be sent on missions on say looking
for trucks in the middle of rainstorms
when it's impossible to see trucks from
fight wing because the ground you know
you can't even see the ground when
you're 500 feet above it but that keeps
the sortie rate high or also say you're
supposed to you know it's raining over a
given target and it's the targets
cladding in but you still send your
planes up there every day five days in a
row by the exact same route in order so
that because that's simply it's like a
factory you keep doing the same routine
we sure telegraphed our punches there
weren't all that many targets in that
area and didn't take too many smarts to
figure out about where the Air Force was
headed especially when we headed him
there day after day making him fly up to
the target before making the go or no-go
decision on the weather that we already
knew was not acceptable then we turned
over the target and came back again the
next day to try again what this meant
for pilots was that they died because
the Vietnamese clearly understood where
the Americans were flying the same
pattern every day and they understood
that they would just keep coming so what
often frequently Vietnamese did was
simply move more and more anti-aircraft
guns into an area that the Americans for
some reason wanted to bomb and what
ended up is American pilots ended up
just fighting flying missions against
empty targets surrounded by hundreds and
hundreds of any aircraft weapons and in
this way by telegraphing our punches
American pilots died I talked with a
couple of nearly apoplectic f4 pilot
said Danang who told me then God they
gone out recently on a on a four plane
mission carrying a very small bomb load
one pilot told me he was gritting his
teeth he was so mad we risked eight guys
he said when we could have hung the
whole load on one plane risking only two
people and done the job better well then
I asked him well why did they send up
four planes
[Music]
the pilot said damned if I know unless
it's just to keep our sortie rate high
but I tell you this it's a goddamn crime
well you know I heard about this sortie
business on aircraft carrier consolation
the Navy pilots had told me they could
do a better job with a few a-sixes
operating in the safety of darkness than
with all those Skyhawk skimming around
with light loads and daylight so while
it didn't seem possible it appeared that
the Navy was trying to out
or tea the air force and air force was
trying to out shorty the Navy the guys
who were flying the sorties took a dim
view of it you had an incredible story
in your book or about how the North
Vietnamese would actually bring down the
American jets with handguns and rifles
almost seems unbelievable to us in a in
an advanced Brewer from American
standpoint it is unbelievable in that
you only see advanced technology system
like a jet fighter bomber needs another
advanced technology like a SAM missile
in order to bring it down and there is a
lot of some truth in that but North
Vietnam underwent a tremendous social
mobilization part of that mobilization
of involved giving almost everyone a gun
be there a pistol a submachine gun a
rifle or whatever or light machine guns
the entire society was organized as a
giant in the air choir any aircraft
system in before really low-level DET
nummies peasants were under instructions
to simply get out in the fields in mass
lie down and shoot up in the air to try
to provide a barrage that would make low
altitudes unsafe American pilots and it
happened the American fighter pilots do
report that several mini planes were
shot down in extremely low level by
peasants and what this meant to them low
level flight became so dangerous they
had to move higher up where they could
consistently be picked up on radar in
other words it isn't just that peasants
could shoot down planes is that but they
denied an airspace to Americans that
made all their operations have more
hazardous
so social mobilization was able to
compensate for technological inferiority
there was another example of this in the
Ho Chi Minh Trail when the United States
built that incredibly expensive
electronic warfare area which the they
were able which the Vietnamese and the
oceans were able to overcome with very
simple tricks the Joint Chiefs of Staff
always wanted to invade North Vietnam
and simply take over Hanoi and Haiphong
or have ground troops in Laos there is a
place where between Laos and Thailand
between the the South China Sea and
Thailand something like 35 miles and so
wide so the effort is the mission was
we'll just forming this magic line and
we'll keep the fooling other out I will
stop them at the pass
do you know literally but since that was
seen as too expensive in terms of troop
lies they ceded that area with
electronic sensors listening devices
sizes that picked up smell sensors of
various kinds these devices in terms and
radio signals to circling aircraft the
aircraft in turn sent them to computer
banks in Thailand in Thailand in turn
organized air strikes over the trail but
two things happen one the sensors were
decoy bags of urine hung in trees tape
recorders with cricket noises in order
to try to mask the movement of trucks
you find a sensor and you put normal
jungle noises a tape of normal jungle
noises next to it so you mask the
sensors in one area while you actually
send your troops and operations on the
other or say you get attacked and you
know you were all convoy drivers truck
drivers North Vietnamese had satchels of
grenades they had rocket flares a lot of
this is good battle is occurring at
night so the enemies would throw out
explosives to make the Americans feel
like they were hitting something and the
Americans in turn wanted to believe that
they were destroying Vietnamese truck
convoys why because pilots are rewarded
on the basis of productivity their
majors and lieutenant Colonel's most of
them want to be full Colonels and
probably assume or desperately want to
be brigadier General's they need to be
productive
therefore there are their tendency is to
report is high a destruction of trucks
as possible and that the big joke
eventually became in in intelligence was
that the next day when reconnaissance
flights would fly out along the Ho Chi
Minh Trail they could never find the
truck carcasses and anywhere near the
numbers that the pilots reported
destroyed so the legend began that deep
in the Laotian jungles live
the great truck eater and the great
truck eater was a monster that totally
loved dead trucks and that and it lives
a nocturnal beast and that every night
he got up and in ate the skeletons of
dread dead trucks so that when the
reconnaissance planes came out in the
morning there were simply be no records
this is not to save thousands of trucks
were destroyed but never to the extent
necessary
remember relatively few supplies were
sent south by American calculations
something like 12 tons a day was enough
to support the war in the south
you can put 12 tons semi-tractor truck
without any problem and has room to
spare or even if you multiply it by
figure 15 or 20 fold say so you have 20
tractor-trailer trucks a day on the Ho
Chi Minh Trail or 40 pickups or whatever
that's still such a small number that
even a very extensive air war has a hard
time or cannot stop that level of
supplies still most of the military
generals and participants in the war
whose memoirs you read and documentary
studied indicated that the u.s. really
won most of the battles of the war that
the UN air records yes right was on its
way to victory and in particular there's
a right-wing revisionist view that the
US could have won the war at the time of
the Tet Offensive at the US build-up of
main core main force units ground troops
began in 65 by the end of 67 we had
someone over 400,000 I think 450,000
maybe even as high as 500,000 troops in
country according to American records
the official rector's kept in the
Pentagon and kept up military assistance
command Vietnam we had just about
destroyed all the Vietcong troops they
were all nearly decimated now why was
that because our records were falsified
as we began as target I talked about
last time once you move into Wars
production process and the officers are
managers they lose their sense of
fidelity to their subordinates below and
since of their fidelity the truth upward
mobility just like in business where men
be going
you know up the ladder is the name of
the game that was a ladder in the
military the currency in warfare was to
report the body count so everybody up
their body count fake body counts were
routine not that not the exceptional and
at each level they worry that the body
counts kept getting higher and higher as
the reports went up the chain of command
the larger the figures became well the
first report I would send in was from
the facts from the information we'd
collected and it was objective as it was
it could be then we sent it in but then
it would always come back doctored up
from higher headquarters that was
standard operating procedure when I was
brigade historian there so the result is
that the battle news was edited and
revised until it was acceptable to the
higher-ups hell I've been ordered to
write open lies on our civil aid program
such as increasing the 15 English
classes at 300 to make it look good of
the politicians and the people back home
and I've been ordered to raise the
figures for food distribution and
refugee villages but I've also had to
retype battle reports though mitting a
certain facts and thereby turning a
North Vietnam Army victory over superior
American forces into a u.s. victory so
on paper we had won but in reality two
things but that was part one of our
victory the second point was in 1967 the
American High Command decided that
Vietcong guerillas no longer existed
because and so they abolished them on
paper because just like American forces
we don't have any part time guerillas
are full time guerrillas and also do
guerillas have 50 to have tanks two
guerrillas have helicopters do
guerrillas have heavy artillery they
don't have as much hardware as we do so
they aren't really a threat to American
units so several hundred thousand are
Vietcong guerillas were abolished from
what's called the order of battle so
once you eliminate the guerillas on
paper and then you so you have a lower
total estimate of enemy forces and you
haven't inflated by a estimate of how
many of those you've killed while we'd
want Lyndon Johnson desperately needed a
political victory in the fall of 67 so
he got general Westmoreland to come back
and say we're winning we're winning that
we're soon going to enter in into Phase
three and that is we're going to mop up
for a couple of years and what was
happening in reality own reality the
Vietcong forces the native the local
forces had expanded radically from 1964
through late 1967 according to US
figures there were only about 200,000
calm but when one CIA man started like
going through the files and trying to
refigure things he calculated about a
half million let's understand what that
means if the CIA man is doubling hid the
estimate that essentially means they
don't have any idea that's how many of
them are are there but it means a double
is probably the highest figure he can
get away with and still be listened to
by anyone so in reality the enemy is
gaining strength we have with through
the Vietcong we have North Vietnamese
participation still and 50,000 troops a
year being sent south in the border
zones along the Cambodian and Laotian
borders and in certain other ichor the
north of the country in the US strategic
offensive had failed of Search and
Destroy the bombing operations had
failed in May January early February
1968 the north beg your pardon the
Vietcong forces attacked in masse
simultaneously for the first time
normally they fought very dispersed
operations they were not under your
under not under notional this is the
first time they've been a simultaneous
national attack the attack succeeded in
driving one it wounded the pacification
where all the units involved in
pacification were driven out of the
countryside into the city
almost all of the Vietnamese in American
ground force units were driven out of
the countryside back into the cities to
defend the cities there and some
Vietcong forces entered cities and
Saigon way of regional capitals and we
began to battle in the cities and what
happened after a few weeks the Vietcong
withdrew from the cities their
casualties were extremely high they had
not anticipated that the Americans would
bomb and conduct artillery strikes
inside the cities but they did so a
large part of South Vietnam was reduced
to rubble their casualties were high but
the Americans in South Vietnamese Army
units were gone from the countryside
desertions had been massive and the
air-con were able to recruit many many
many people now that there were no
opposing forces in the countryside their
political cadres were able to surface so
they were weakened in many ways but in
the other hand they had achieved a
decisive victory in driving their
opponents out of the countryside now
from what is the legend then because
American forces were able to kill many
of the commandos and Vietcong troops
inside the cities the Americans of
general Westmoreland declared victory of
course this ignores the fact that
although he's driven the Vietcong out of
the cities he himself has been driven
out of the countryside and that it's
made a mockery out of his own previous
claims of victory
also as Sparkletts clear to many many
people that there were far more enemies
in South Vietnam than the Americans have
been willing to admit
Westmoreland then made a troop request
for another 200,000 soldiers this
recruit request went under severe
analysis essentially what was found was
that it within the production model of
war if you were just going to fight the
same kind of warfare but simply add more
resources to it still the Viet Cong
alone just the people in the South could
fight on for another four or five years
or at least three years to four years
and then with anymore
was significant North Vietnamese
participation they could fight on ten to
twenty years and was you just we just
could not drive the other side bankrupt
and you're saying that the North
Vietnamese Army basically hadn't
participated not intent not intent the
North Vietnamese Army did not
participate into it in fact in most of
the war they really played a minimal
role when you consider the number of
Vietcong troops in proportion to the
number of North well that's true up
until 68 after 68 they entered the war
in larger numbers the Vietcong were hit
nor was certainly the conservative claim
that the at home took severe losses in
the Tet Offensive is true the claim that
they were decimated and defeated his
false in the claim that the Americans
won Tet is false
Ted essentially made help the American
War managers at least the part of them
see that their strategy was bankrupt and
that there was no path to victory so
this finally created a remember Linda
Johnson assigned somewhere during this
period that's right not too long after
it was this kind of a break in their
self delusion the techno war would win
every now here is a serious problem that
people do not understand American
television news again from night from
mid late 1968 on began report the idea
that the world was winding down and that
we were on our way out this is not true
this is a false statement
you should never believe this when you
look at the casualty figures of how many
American soldiers were killed from 65
through 68 462 through 67 and then you
take 68 and then you look 69 through 73
the 69 through 73 is just about as
within a couple of hundred is high as
the number of killed
65 through 67 week search-and-destroy
continued way way on until until Oh late
71 what was it then that finally
convinced the u.s. foreign policy
establishment or in the US public that
Vietnam couldn't be won for mid 68 on
the American military began to become
progressively more Restless and by
certainly by blade 69 70s an active
revolt against
commanders remember that 75% of the
battles in Vietnam were initiated by the
enemy and the average American grunt
spent his tour of duty that those few
who were combat troops finished her of
Duty walking into ambushes most men
learned fairly quickly that while they
were walking in ambushes that their
generals were getting medals and they
were safe in helicopters on his own and
so forth so people begin what's called
fragging fragging means you take a
fragmentation grenade and you throw it
at your superior whether it's a
noncommissioned officer a sergeant or a
lieutenant or a captain or whatever it
was a way to tell higher command not to
treat the ground troops lives
frivolously that they would not pursue
aggressively pursue dangerous combat
situations that simply in order to make
the loot to make the superiors look good
well let me tell you how it work we'd
start having war calls which is like oh
well at midnight everybody an outfit
starts opening fire and screaming gooks
on the wire gooks on the wire and the
barbed wire fences you know and then you
try to kill any of the lifers that you
didn't like so we tried to get the co a
couple of times the machine-gun one time
his rack took nine holes his cot nine
bullet holes but he drove out of it and
got away everybody be shooting so he
couldn't check the weapon see who's
shooting him so they'd be throwing
grenades at the wire and yelling and
shouting gooks on the wire gooks and
they'd blow the siren and then run
around and half the guys be facing out
where it's shooting and then the other
half would be waiting for a lifer to
come out of his tent
yeah I've seen whole officers executed
five or six times just put a price on
his head
next one the kills and gets the money
next time he was out on a mission
everybody knew it was going to happen
they just wait till he was in the right
position and the estimates run quite
high and it was the official army count
is about 650 fagging incidents and there
are real reasons to doubt that because
it's a quiet
I'm sure there were a lot of them they
weren't reported oh of course because no
no commander wants to have what do you
say it's like some of my own men threw a
grenade at me or tried to shoot me I
mean how is that gonna look good on your
record are you going to get promoted up
the up as a great leader when you're
reporting that your own people are
shooting at you no I'm sure the records
are ma the figures must be substantially
higher the soldiers even put pools of
money out for contracts for particularly
unpopular officers but there's also
suicide and self-mutilation the went on
to people who got desperate if they were
this the they were disoriented they were
not being cared for by their own command
the actual operations often involve
slaughter of innocents suicide rates are
fairly high standing up in the middle of
firefight there's one famous cartoon
book by a man named tad Forster and it
shows a picture of a man of a soldier
hiding behind a rock with his trigger
finger in the air looking for the
million-dollar wound that they're being
like if he exposed this and got his
index finger shot off that he could get
out of the war zone or you don't take
your malaria pill we're gonna get them
therefore removed because you're
incapacitated with malaria there are
many many ways of people shooting
themselves in the foot
there are lots and lots of stories of
self-mutilation or you do it to your
friend in other words if your friend is
had been wounded twice and you're in a
particularly dangerous mission and he's
had a premonition of death which was
taken very very seriously all combat
soldiers are deeply superstitious then
sometimes you shoot or you you could you
stab your friend not not in a vial of
place but to win them enough to get them
out you just you can't fight a war of
its way you cannot fight a war where
people are are you going searching a
void also in a void that's the that was
a very prevalent thing to accept Search
and Destroy searching a void that is you
go out and you play you play war you try
to like you go out and you smoke some
dope and you fake some radio reports or
you generally try not to engage the
enemy yes we talked about it every day
all the guys felt the same way we just
weren't accomplishing anything
FAK some guys were so depressed and
disgusted they was killing themselves
some guys were taking hand grenades and
blowing themselves away they couldn't
take the strain anymore
God is really heavy I don't think a lot
of this stuff was reported GIS would
just kill themselves in the army who'd
probably send the stats home that the
guy was killed or missing in action did
the anti-war movement at home have any
effect on these soldiers in creating a
sense of what their what they were doing
was wrong that there were victims they
were making mistakes did that have
impact you think on this there was a
wide coffeehouse GI coffeehouse movement
the anti-war movement tried to set up
coffee houses near us basis to promote
literature and things but honestly when
you read soldiers memoirs and novels
they notice Lee don't talk about the
anti-war movement very much it's not to
say there wasn't an influence but they
talk about reacting to the situation of
warfare that they're in the one and in
the in with the moral qualms are the
moral qualms that are seen on the
battlefield the one clear influence of
the anti-war movement is nobody wouldn't
be the last man to die in Vietnam I mean
once it was stated that the US was going
to withdraw eventually that made it more
difficult there was one place in your
book where you said that this actually
was a class war class warfare that was
going on and that black black soldiers
were at the forefront of the fragging
and the revolt let's remember who went
to Vietnam after World War two the US
military decided that too many
college-educated men had been killed the
danger of this was that it was going to
hurt the scientific base of the country
at the scientific base was no other
country was hurt we couldn't have a next
generation of weapons so the idea of the
2's deferment of the college deferment
was to keep the pool alive with this
meant was remember this is an era of
very few student loans very few
scholarships and so forth it meant that
the sons of the middle class could go to
college with the sons of the
in class went to the military in the
military itself military needs vast
numbers of white-collar skills so if you
had any kind of like clerical skills
like middle-class people do often do
typing filing so on you could ease more
readily get a non-combat job what this
translated into is that when she started
got down to the point of who was in your
infantry units your armor and artillery
they were overwhelmed they were
disproportionately minorities and rural
whites poor rural whites poor urban
whites so we had a a working class
largely working-class military combat
military whereas a more middle-class
anti-war movement in a more middle-class
logistic apparatus and in the military
so as a class revolt a class revolt no I
wouldn't call it revolution we're not
talking about these people were not
socialist now but it is sort of like
this revolt against the manager yes it's
not in our interest they're exploiting
and using yes and yeah and it's
certainly with among black soldiers that
they're they they were definitely
influenced by the Black Power movement
racial consciousness and critical
consciousness was very paramount and
where many of the Thai signs of bonding
signs of you know the skin and special
handshake so on and so forth
how would you evaluate the mass media
handling of Vietnam then and now I spent
a long time looking at the tapes and I
had was closed it's like I finished my
outline I was going to write a book
about television news covers the war and
I decided to think well what was not on
the news frame what I saw and that's
constantly I wrote this other book the
perfect war what's on the news is a lot
of pictures of helicopters a lot of
pictures of jets a lot of pictures of
tanks a lot of hardware and which
tegmental war was the major
representation to visual representation
and along with these predictably these
these these presentations of these
beautiful weapons under my favorite was
an ABC show an ABC series where they
first went out and they see the
battleship New Jersey battleship New
Jersey had just been recommissioned in
69 and we see here's this 16
guns and there's this giant 30-foot
phallus that the camera looks down and
God starts talking about it shoots a 250
pound projectile 16 miles go from 32
feet of reinforced concrete or maybe I
had that the other way maybe it's 32
miles 16 feet of reinforced gettin is a
250 yards kill radius and it's simply
like the man is the the correspondent
become a salesperson and like I thought
gosh I too want the battleship New
Jersey you know missus is cool beyond
belief and then the film cuts and
there's another correspondent and he's
on the the bank of a river and it's
about the VC fling flying trashcan and
if you remember the Roadrunner Rockets
you know about Wiley coyote was always
getting something from Acme rocket
company that always kind of looked like
a trash can on a stick with a kind of
like triangle on top of it that's
exactly what this rocket looked like was
obviously of a homemade crude rocket and
the contrast is so great and it seems
like American victory is so insured
because we're of our technical
superiority of course what they don't
point out the Vietcong who fires that
rocket knows exactly what he's shooting
it was the battleship New Jersey
very rarely knew where its bullets were
flying so that's what the people saw
people saw about people did not not see
very many dead people there were very
few there the def convention on the news
was much like a woman of your westerns
no no real gore they saw a body count
each week which showed that we were
always winning
we saw one village one village was
burned in 1965 that's it
and the guy and the guy with
correspondent got in severe trouble male
I appeared as is remember did not come
from the news of it didn't come from the
normal networks it came from a veteran
who tried hard to get the news out very
little coverage of massacres came on the
ordinary language of the war gooks slope
slant dink no American news
correspondent ever talked about those
terms of what they meant never it simply
did not occur instead was very much an
official perspective where Gwen got
critical from 68 on occasionally you
would see reports about failed
technology and occasionally you would
see stories about tragic American deaths
but it was sort of like a human-interest
tragedy becomes the limit of criticism
rather than any kind of
explanitory notion of why we aren't
succeeding bill let's talk about
evaluation of the Vietnam War a lot of
people written books about it historians
in generals etc well let's listen in it
was just to come back to where we
started to this other point my analysis
says the u.s. had to get out we couldn't
fight because we had an army that
wouldn't do it anymore now you could
join you could move to air force
campaigns but air force campaigns have
their problems too you can't hold ground
with airplanes sending money to the
south vietnamese they were corrupt
they've just had more money to be
correct with so we were defeated my
analysis says the united states was
defeated and that that's that's the
standpoint so the question is how have
the historians and the novelist and so
on treated the subject of american
defeat the conventional path is a
liberal interpretation that is it's just
as tragedy it's just things were wrong
out there somewhere and like it's just
like there were all sorts of small
mistakes of honorable men making small
to small decisions or Schlessinger be
all this licensure would be the most
payment the classical case stanley
Carnales book and PBS series the most
recent example but the notion of tragedy
is not an explanation even twenty years
of small mistakes doesn't explain a war
that has a very clear structure which is
my argument at the structural
contradictions of that mode of warfare
ended in its dissolution and failure the
second school the most is prominent
right now is that us lost because of
self-imposed restraints suppose
restrains is a military term often used
in Joint Chiefs of Staff documents
calling for escalated air war and their
vision is that the United States should
have invaded North Vietnam in 1966 and
taken Hanoi and Haiphong of course the
only problem with that or every one of
those peasants have had those guns
fighting against shooting against the
aircraft the jet fighter pilots they
were also organized and prepared for
invasion Doug you mentioned why do you
know you mentioned the fact that the
North Vietnamese didn't have very many
troops in the South that was one of the
major reasons it wasn't that they didn't
want to help their comrades and their
southern comrades
it was troops were being held back in
the car home to protect the homefront
against a possible American invasion
according to Gao the plan for you to
fight a u.s. invasion was to let local
militia and regional forces
fight for the first day to two days so
once the Americans were tired after 24
to 48 hours of constant combat then the
North Vietnamese army went into the
scene and where did this notion that the
US could have had a successful invasion
it's just the the most bizarre unreal
fantasy unworthy of any kind of serious
consideration and even if they had put
an expeditionary force in Hanoi and
Haiphong we still that would change the
class structure in South Vietnam that
wouldn't change the fact that you had a
peasantry that wanted land that you
wanted Buddhists who wanted
self-determination rather than Catholic
rule and that you wanted that a whole
country wanted national reunification
because the whole basis of the culture
was throwing out the foreign invader and
that's all they done all their lives for
two thousand years was throw out the
Chinese the French and now the America
that was it it wouldn't have changed it
the self-imposed restraint still is
fault well have we learned anything
since then we you point out the total
corruption and self delusion of the
military and the civilian leaders
throughout this first of all thinking
they could wage a techno war and
secondly having not paying attention to
the realities which might try to seep up
from the intelligence field suppressing
any intelligence that would contrary
would contrary to what they wanted are
we still in that same mode of thinking
yeah do where everything applying it to
we already have a couple places
certainly Grenada was one example we
took Grenada and we just barely took it
even though there was a minimum
opposition most of the US Special Forces
commandos bit the dust in various
operations because the various mishaps
of one kind or another
also the military's analysis is well not
only did we fight with one hand tied
behind our back but we fought too slow
we need a more rapid escalation
so Honduras has been prepared a series
of airfields and ports had been prepared
in Honduras in order to bring 40 50
thousand troops into battle within a
week they have the facilities for this
and they still have many of the military
have the delusion that they could
probably take Managua in a few other
places in a couple of weeks rather than
an extensive Central America war which
would ask
tremendously because the nicaraguan said
they're of no choice except to expand
the war outside of Nicaragua to make the
battlefield bigger the battlefields
bigger than the United States has to
disperse its troops its disparate troops
are dispersed camp chief victory back to
it back to Vietnam I'd like to have
learned to think they have not learned a
thing but then Arthur most haven't
learned a thing their mayor veterans of
course than the US who now who certainly
don't want to see this they're probably
parts of the military and very
subordinate positions who don't want to
see a major escalation but generally
we're on track for another kind of major
intervention whether or not it will be
since the Iran Agua a crisis has emerged
that may be off for a while I don't know
but they're certainly Philippines
there's another growing insurgency there
the Chan the chances for another major
intervention and another series of
self-delusions are very very high
because the people the officer corps who
were successful in Vietnam are the
people who are in charge now
the people who would the dissonance
though the few handfuls of lieutenant
Colonel's and majors who were just got
repulsed they got out they resigned most
of them did ironically the army itself
recognized this in 1970 in a war college
study which indicated that there is a
significant difference between the ideal
army values such as honesty integrity
bravery justice and responsibility and
the real values which are practiced by
the military in order to promote career
advancement here is the study's
conclusion the present climate does not
appear to be self-correcting the human
drives for success and recognition by
seniors sustained if not inflamed by the
system of rewards and management which
cater to immediate personal success at
the expense of moral and ethical values
would appear to only be perpetuated by
the current environment the fact alone
that the leaders of the future are those
who survived and excelled within the
rules of the present system militates in
part against any self starting
incremental return toward the practical
application of ideal army values and
then that final reason I note the
problem of learning is that there are
cultural reasons that make the American
people want to believe the self imposed
restrain school and that is we are used
to the dition of the cowboy who comes in
and saves a society against the enemies
when the power structure cannot defend
itself the idea of a weak Authority that
has to be saved by a warrior shows up in
many places in American cultures in the
Western in the detective hero the
detective hero is outside the law all
the Superman and the masked Avenger
figures of the 20s and 30s certainly are
able to foil criminals that legal
authorities cannot but also this is a
deep belief that technology cannot fail
certainly an American vulture that if we
have enough technological or military
force we can't help but win a war it's
people it's hard not to believe in your
hardware Americans don't learn about
social relations they don't learn about
class structure everyday in the
newspaper or about cultural history
every day in the newspaper they learn
about what's for sale then what is the
lesson of Vietnam concerning the limits
of Technol war the situations in which
techno or the world but it cannot
achieve victory they can destroy land it
can destroy people but it can't create a
government and grant can't create a
culture it can't create a society I mean
this is another thing we tried to do in
Vietnam to impose the model of the
consumer society on them and
american-style
supposed democracy whether it be
elections in situations where these just
couldn't work oh well it did work in a
way and then when jihad people can
become corrupted they did get into their
drugs and their Honda's and things but
it just doesn't build a stable Society
it doesn't build a dead will people who
are willing to die for that society that
was the whole problem they had you has
plenty of corrupted Vietnamese but when
it looks like things were near they
weren't willing to go out and defend
Saigon to the death or not they just did
they bought their tickets out to the
United States whereas the peasants were
willing to fight the death just for land
and just for getting rid of their
landlords or local oppressors it made
perfect sense to them and there's been
this problem the so called Vietnam
syndrome which our leaders have been
complaining about all these years as if
there was a sickness in the land at the
loss of will to fight yet and but it
looks like the American public had a
clearer picture of what the war was all
about than the than the leaders but what
do you how would you assess that and do
you think they were overcoming that
Vietnam syndrome now sort of thinking
well I don't think the American public
ever had an idea what was wrong they
just knew something was wrong and that
it wasn't getting better I think I think
I need their fuzziness made it easier
for people to believe the self impose
restraint school to believe that we lost
because we didn't fight hard enough for
the past except a few years popular
culture is presenting the hero that the
warrior imagery as well very much strong
on the rise with has many classical war
movies made and several kind of variant
war movies made it's definitely a war
culture how people though clearly though
there's there's still a resistance
there's still a certain level in which
the disaster of Vietnam is etched in at
least some people's memories and even
though it's they don't have an
understanding of why it failed or what
the structural reasons there is a fear
that it will happen again